Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Hello and welcome to the Rest Is History World Cup special. We're going through all the various countries that are competing in this year's World Cup. And a couple of days ago, I very much focused on Dido, the legendary founder of the city of Carthage. And Dominic, today you have someone with the name Gannibal, which is, I gather, the Russian, the way the Russians pronounce Hannibal, the great military hero, conqueror of the Carthaginians. But this person is, he's not a Carthaginian, is he? He is from today's country, which is Cameroon.
感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要获取每周独家加更节目、无广告收听、系列节目抢先看，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。大家好，欢迎收听《历史的余烬》世界杯特别节目。我们将带大家了解今年世界杯参赛的各个国家。几天前，我重点讲了迦太基城的传奇创始人狄多。多米尼克，你今天带来的这个人名字叫加尼巴尔（Gannibal），据我所知，这就是俄语中对汉尼拔（Hannibal）的发音，而汉尼拔是伟大的军事英雄、迦太基人的征服者。但这个人，他并不是迦太基人，对吧？他是来自如今的哪个国家——喀麦隆。
He is from Cameroon. So I don't know how au fait you are. Or is he? Well, we should come to this. How au fait are you with Cameroonian history generally, Tom? Probably not as au fait as I could be. Well, I think it's fair to say that a lot of Cameroonian history is terra incognita for many Britishish and indeed
他来自喀麦隆。所以我不知道你对喀麦隆历史了解多少。或者说他真的是吗？好吧，我们一会儿会谈到这个。汤姆，你对喀麦隆的历史总体了解多少？可能没有我希望的那么深入。好吧，我觉得可以说，对于许多英国甚至说英语的听众来说，喀麦隆的大部分历史都是未知的领域……
english-speaking listeners so i mean cameroon historically was never obviously a single nation state it was a place of competing kingdoms and chieftains do you know where the name cameroon comes from i didn't know this actually until i looked it up no it comes from our friends the portuguese i guess probably most, that would make sense. So there's a river. I think the only thing I know about Cameroon is Roger Miller. Right, 1990. Yeah, 1990.
所以我的意思是，从历史上看，喀麦隆显然从来都不是一个单一的民族国家，而是一个由相互竞争的王国和部落首领组成的地方。你知道“喀麦隆”这个名字是怎么来的吗？其实我查了资料才知道，不知道。不，它来自我们的朋友葡萄牙人，我猜大概大部分都是这样，这就合理了。所以那里有一条河。我想我对喀麦隆唯一的了解就是罗杰·米拉。没错，1990年。对，1990年。
We got to the quarterfinals, I think, in the World Cup. They did get to the quarterfinals and lost to Gary Lineker's England. I don't really know anything else beyond that. So I'm looking forward to being educated. There's a river called the Wurri. And the Portuguese, when they sailed up that in the 16th century, it was full of shrimps. And they called it the Rio dos Camarões.
我记得我们在世界杯上打入了四分之一决赛。他们的确打入了四分之一决赛，然后输给了加里·莱因克尔领衔的英格兰队。除此之外，我真的什么都不知道了。所以我很期待被科普一番。有一条河叫乌里河（Wurri）。葡萄牙人在16世纪航行到那里时，发现河里满是虾。于是他们把它命名为“虾河”（Rio dos Camarões）。
Okay. And that became Cameroon. So it could have been Langostino or something if the Spanish had got there. Yes, very good. Very good. Well, anyway, what's now cameroon was colonized by the germans and then it was divided up between um britain and france at the end of the first world war and then obviously became independent but although this is a podcast
好吧。然后这就演变成了喀麦隆。所以如果西班牙人先到那里，它可能会变成“小龙虾”（Langostino）或者别的什么。是的，非常对。非常对。总之，现在的喀麦隆曾被德国人殖民，后来在第一次世界大战结束后被英国和法国瓜分，再后来显然独立了。但尽管这是一个关于喀麦隆历史以及喀麦隆最著名的儿子之一的播客……
about the history of cameroon and about one of cameroon's most famous um sons we're not going to start in Cameroon, Tom. We're going to start somewhere completely unexpected and completely different. So we're going to start on a place called the Black River in St. Petersburg, then the capital of Russia. We're going to start in February 1837. So there are two men on the bank of this river. And one of them is a French officer and sort of man about town and Lothario called Georges Charles Dantes, very sort of Three Musketeers-ish character. And the other is Russia's most beloved poet, Alexander Pushkin. So the man who is seen by many people as the most beautiful of all Russian writers, the man who kind of invented the Russian literary language, an icon of Russia.
汤姆，我们不打算从喀麦隆开始。我们要从一个完全意想不到、完全不同地方开始。我们要从圣彼得堡的黑河（Black River）开始，那里曾是俄罗斯的首都。我们要从1837年2月开始。当时这条河的岸边有两个男人。其中一个是法国军官、某种程度上的社交名流兼浪子，名叫乔治·查尔斯·丹特斯（Georges Charles Dantes），这是一个非常带有《三个火枪手》色彩的人物。另一个是俄罗斯最受爱戴的诗人亚历山大·普希金。因此，这个人被许多人视为所有俄罗斯作家中最伟大的一位，是他创造了俄罗斯文学语言，是俄罗斯的偶像。
And they are fighting a duel. They've been leading up to this for weeks. There's been a lot of hostility between them, sort of romantic hostility and so on to do with jealousy and so on, which I won't go into. So it's a duel to the death. Dantes fires first and he hits Pushkin in the stomach and Pushkin falls and he manages to rise and shoot back at Dantes, but he only lightly wounds him and then he falls back and Pushkin is mortally wounded and he dies. So this is the end of Russia's greatest poet. Now there's great mourning for Pushkin. And later that year, a magazine or newspaper that he
他们正在进行决斗。这事已经酝酿好几个星期了。他们之间存在很多敌意，某种浪漫方面的敌意等等，涉及嫉妒之类的事情，我就不细说了。这是一场生死决斗。丹特斯先开枪，他击中了普希金的腹部，普希金倒了下去，但他设法站了起来，向丹特斯开枪还击，却只轻微地打伤了对方，接着他又倒了下去，普希金受了致命伤，最终死去。这就是俄罗斯最伟大诗人的结局。现在，人们对普希金展开了极大的哀悼。同年晚些时候，他创立的一本……
founded, a journal that he founded called Sovremenik, publishes one of Pushkin's unfinished works. And this is a novel, not a poem. And it's called the more of peter the great and pushkin had worked on it 10 years or so before and it's the story of this hero ibrahim the more who comes from somewhere in africa we don't really know where and he comes to st petersburg and uh to paris spends time in paris has a love affair with a French countess. He eventually ends up back in St. Petersburg. There's a ball at the Winter Palace. There are dinners of noblemen. It's very kind of war and peace. Pushkin didn't finish it and it's published, but it means an awful lot to Pushkin because actually this is a portrait of his great
他创立的一家杂志或报纸、一本名为《现代人》（Sovremenik）的期刊发表了普希金的一部未完成作品。这是一部小说，而不是一首诗。书名叫《彼得大帝的黑奴》（The Moor of Peter the Great），普希金大约在十年前就开始创作了。故事讲述了英雄易卜拉欣——这个来自非洲某个我们并不真正确知的黑奴——来到圣彼得堡，以及……去巴黎，在巴黎度过了一段时光，与一位法国女伯爵有一段恋情。他最终回到了圣彼得堡。冬宫里举行了舞会，还有贵族的晚宴。这非常有一种《战争与和平》的感觉。普希金没有写完它，它就被发表了，但这对于普希金来说意义重大，因为实际上这是他曾祖父的肖像……
grandfather, the moor of St. Petersburg. And this is what's going to link it back to Cameroon. Because Pushkin's great-grandfather was an African who had come to St. Petersburg at the beginning of the 18th century. And this mattered enormously to Pushkin. He wasn't embarrassed by it at all. He would often draw self-portraits of himself with exaggerated kind of artwork. He saw his African features. He had an inkwell on his desk in the shape of an African page boy. In his most famous poem, Evgeny Onegin, there is a line
圣彼得堡的黑奴。这就是它与喀麦隆的联系所在。因为普希金的曾祖父是一个非洲人，他在18世纪初来到了圣彼得堡。这对于普希金来说极其重要。他对此一点也不感到尴尬。他经常画自己的自画像，带有某种夸张的艺术风格。他看到了自己的非洲特征。他的书桌上有一个非洲男童造型的墨水瓶。在他最著名的长篇叙事诗《叶甫盖尼·奥涅金》中，有一行诗……
where the narrator imagines himself under the sky of my Africa, sighing for gloomy Russia. So to Pushkin himself, his African ancestry was a sort of, it was a claim to a kind of romanticism. You know, it gave him an exoticism that nobody else in Russia had. And the man from whom Pushkin traced his ancestry, was a man called Avram Petrovich Ganebel. Ganebel. Yeah, Ganebel. But Dominic, presumably, not originally his name. No, not originally his name. We shall come to how he got his name.
叙述者想象自己置身于“我的非洲”的天空下，为阴郁的俄罗斯叹息。因此，对普希金本人而言，他的非洲血统是一种浪漫主义的宣示。你知道，这赋予了他一种俄罗斯其他任何人都没有的异国情调。而普希金追溯其血统的那个人，是一个名叫阿夫拉姆·彼得罗维奇·加尼巴尔（Avram Petrovich Gannibal）的人。加尼巴尔。对，加尼巴尔。但多米尼克，这推测并非他原本的名字吧？不，并非他原本的名字。我们稍后会讲到他是如何得到这个名字的。
Now, Avram, but basically Ibrahim. Yeah, Ibrahim. So that's the link with the Moor in the story. Now, Pushkin, what did he think about this great-grandfather? He did not think he came from Cameroon. He actually thought that he came from Abyssinia, from Ethiopia. And lots of Russians believed this at the time. There had been this character called Gannibal who had come from Abyssinia. And this seems almost certainly wrong. So if Ethiopia is a Christian country. Yes. So is that a part of, but Ibrahim is obviously the Muslim name.
现在，阿夫拉姆，基本上就是易卜拉欣。对，易卜拉欣。所以这就是故事中那个黑奴的联系。那么，普希金是如何看待这位曾祖父的呢？他不认为自己来自喀麦隆。他实际上认为他来自阿比西尼亚，也就是今天的埃塞俄比亚。当时许多俄罗斯人都这样认为。曾有这样一个名叫加尼巴尔的人物来自阿比西尼亚。但这几乎肯定是错的。如果埃塞俄比亚是一个基督教国家。是的。那么这是否属于……但易卜拉欣显然是个穆斯林名字。
Of course. So why do they think he might come from Ethiopia? Because if you're Russian, and your Orthodox Christianity means a lot to you, but also if you're aspiring to join the nobility and to make your way up in society, it's important to you to have an ancestor who has come from the preeminent Christian kingdom, this mysterious, exotic Christian land called Abyssinia. That's why- Prestigion. Exactly, the land of Prestigion. Now, many years later, we'll get into Gannibal's story in a second. Many years later, another great Russian writer, Vladimir Nabokov, he was really the first to say, I don't think Gannibal did come from Ethiopia at all. And he thought Gannibal might have come from
当然。那他们为什么会觉得他可能来自埃塞俄比亚呢？因为如果你是一个俄罗斯人，你的东正教信仰对你而言意义重大，但同时如果你渴望加入贵族阶层并在社会中向上流动，拥有一个来自最卓越的基督教王国的祖先对你来说就很重要，这个神秘、异域情调的基督教土地名叫阿比西尼亚。这就是为什么……声望。没错，普雷斯特·约翰（Prester John）的土地。多年以后，我们稍后会深入探讨加尼巴尔的故事。多年以后，另一位伟大的俄罗斯作家弗拉基米尔·纳博科夫（Vladimir Nabokov），他是第一个真正站出来说“我认为加尼巴尔根本不是来自埃塞俄比亚”的人。他认为加尼巴尔可能来自……
Cameroon, from the sort of northeastern fringes of Cameroon. A Beninese historian called Judone Grimanku studied the pattern of the slave trade. Now you'll see in a second why that's important. And he also said, I think Cameroon is the most likely place. And finally, there was a British writer about 15 years ago called Hugh Barnes, who also studied Gannibal. They found that Pushkin's great-grandfather had applied at one point for a coat of arms from the Tsarina, and that Gannibal had asked for a particular mysterious word, Tom, to be put on the coat of arms. And that word was F-U-M-M-O. And in the local Kotoko language of that part of Cameroon, that word means homeland. Goodness.
喀麦隆，来自喀麦隆的东北部边缘。一位名叫朱多内·格里曼库（Judone Grimanku）的贝宁历史学家研究了奴隶贸易的模式。大家一会儿就会明白为什么这很重要。他也表示，他认为喀麦隆是最有可能的地方。最后，大约15年前，有一位名叫休·巴恩斯（Hugh Barnes）的英国作家也研究了加尼巴尔。他们发现普希金的曾祖父曾一度向沙皇女皇申请过族徽，并且加尼巴尔要求在一个特定的神秘词汇，汤姆，被印在族徽上。那个词就是 F-U-M-M-O。在喀麦隆那部分的当地科托科语（Kotoko）中，这个词的意思是“故乡”。天哪。
Goodness. Well, Dominic, just before you move on to that, i just ask is so is he does cameroon today claim him is he he's not as big a figure in cameroon i think as he is in russia interesting interestingly um but yes cameroon does claim him actually funny enough ethiopia and eritrea sort of squabbled over who who um yanibal belonged to and the truth is he didn't belong to either he belonged to cameroon so there's a little bit of a sort of African tug of war, but I think it matters more to Russians than it does to anybody else. So let's start by looking at what we know of Gannibal's life. So he probably is born Ibrahim, probably. And he grows up south of Lake Chad in equatorial Africa in what's now Cameroon. And what seems likely is that he was the son of a chief.
天哪。好吧，多米尼克，在你继续讲下去之前，我想问的是，现在的喀麦隆会认领他吗？他在喀麦隆是一个大人物吗，我想可能不像在俄罗斯那样，有趣的是……但确实，喀麦隆确实认领了他。说来也巧，埃塞俄比亚和厄立特里亚曾为加尼巴尔究竟属于谁而争吵过，但事实是，他既不属于这两者，他属于喀麦隆。所以这里有一点非洲式的拉锯战，但我认为这对于俄罗斯人来说，比对其他任何人都更重要。那么，让我们从了解加尼巴尔的生活开始。所以他可能出生时叫易卜拉欣，很有可能。他在赤道非洲查德湖以南、即如今的喀麦隆长大的。看起来很有可能他是某个酋长的儿子。
I mean, that might have been self-publicity. It might have been making a romantic story for himself. A chief with more than a dozen children. And in about 1703, when young Ibrahim was six, probably, he was kidnapped by slavers. Because there's a lot of slaving going on from the Arab world, isn't there? Oh, absolutely. So the slaving is not just European. The slave trade from Central Africa and East Africa up to the Mediterranean or into the Red Sea and the Indian Ocean is colossal in the early 18th century
我的意思是，这可能只是一种自我宣传。这可能只是他为自己编造的一个浪漫故事。一个拥有十几个孩子的酋长。大约在1703年，当小易卜拉欣大约六岁时，他被奴隶贩子绑架了。因为当时来自阿拉伯世界的奴隶贸易很猖獗，对吧？哦，绝对是的。所以奴隶贸易不仅仅是欧洲人的事。在18世纪初……
and the late 17th century. So I mean, in total, over the centuries, there are millions of people being enslaved and shipped across the sea. And he is one of them. And roughly 1703, 1704, let's call him Avram, he ends up in Constantinople. So he's sold into slavery and he ends up at the court of the Ottoman Emperor, Sultan Ahmed III. And he's there, we think, for about a year. Okay, another question. So if there are millions and millions of slaves going from Africa up to the Middle East, to end up not just in Constantinople but in the the sultan's palace i mean you have to what is it about him that gets him there because that's very kind of high-end destination isn't it he's a page boy but i think there would have been many such slaves tom i don't think he's an unusual
和17世纪末，从中非和东非经陆路运往地中海，或运往红海和印度洋的奴隶贸易规模是极其庞大的。所以我的意思是，几个世纪以来，总共有数百万人在被奴役后通过海路被运走。他就是其中之一。大约在1703年、1704年，我们暂且称他为阿夫拉姆，他最终来到了君士坦丁堡。他被当作奴隶卖掉，并最终进入了奥斯曼帝国苏丹艾哈迈德三世（Sultan Ahmed III）的宫廷。我们认为他在那里呆了大约一年。好的，还有一个问题。如果成百上千万的奴隶从非洲运到中东，最终不仅能到君士坦丁堡，还能进入苏丹的宫殿，我的意思是，你必须……他身上有什么特质能让他到达那里？因为那是非常高级的目的地，对吧？他是一个男童侍从，但我认为当时会有很多这样的奴隶，汤姆，我不认为他是一个不寻常的人物。
figure so just luck basically i think it's pure luck right because and it's and it's good luck for him as it will turn out because his prominence there means that he catches the eye of visiting ambassadors and diplomats and so on. And one of these people is a man called Count Sava Lukic Vladislavic Raguzinski. And this man, great name, crazy name, crazy guy. He was a fur merchant and adventurer who had been hanging around with Peter the Great a couple couple of years earlier and is he a massive lad like peter the great was i think he is a huge party in the rest of history smashing up john evelyn's house in deptford didn't he yes he did that's right yeah and going on wheelbarrow races around his garden exactly peter the great is now the Tsar of Russia And He said
所以纯粹是运气咯？我想这纯粹是运气，对吧？因为……这对他的日后发展来说是好运，他在那里的显赫地位意味着他引起了来访的大使和外交官等人的注意。这些人中有一个人名叫萨瓦·卢基奇·弗拉迪斯拉维奇-拉古津斯基伯爵（Count Sava Lukic Vladislavic Raguzinski）。这个人，名字很棒，疯狂的名字，疯狂的家伙。他是一个皮毛商人和冒险家，几年前曾和彼得大帝混在一起。他是个像彼得大帝那样的大块头吗？我觉得他块头很大。《历史的余烬》里讲过他大闹约翰·伊夫林（John Evelyn）在代特福德（Deptford）的家，对吧？是的，他确实这么干了，没错，哈哈。还在他花园里进行独轮车比赛。没错，彼得大帝当时已经是俄罗斯沙皇了，他说……
Peter the Great collects Curiosities Like a lot of European monarchs At the turn of the 18th century He has a cabinet of curiosities Wow, I've seen it Have you? Yeah, it's in St. Petersburg
彼得大帝像18世纪初的许多欧洲君主一样收集奇珍异宝，他有一个珍宝柜。哇，我见过。是吗？对，就在圣彼得堡。
But not with the living specimens in it No, not with the living specimens But no, it's in St. Petersburg Opposite the Hermitage Right It's very, very Is it good? Yeah, but Creepy Living specimens. But no, it's in St. Petersburg opposite the Hermitage. Right. It's very, very... Is it good? Yeah, but creepy.
但里面可没有活体标本。对，没有活体标本。不，它在圣彼得堡，埃米塔日博物馆（Hermitage）对面。没错。非常非常……好玩吗？对，但是毛骨悚然。
Creepy, I was going to say. Very, very creepy. He apparently had... I mean, we know that Peter the Great was a great fan of dwarves and throwing dwarves around at banquets and things. It's kind of two-headed dwarves preserved in formaldehyde. I mean, there's a lot of that. He supposedly had a baby with two heads and a lamb with eight legs exactly they are still there as i remember so what peter the great says to uh count sarva
毛骨悚然，我正想这么说。非常非常毛骨悚然。他显然有……我的意思是，我们知道彼得大帝是侏儒的狂热爱好者，喜欢在宴会上把侏儒扔来扔去之类的事情。里面有很多诸如保存在福尔马林里的双头侏儒之类的东西。我的意思是，有很多这样的展品。据说他还有一个双头婴儿和一只八条腿的羊。没错，据我所记，它们现在还在那里。所以彼得大帝对萨瓦伯爵说……
his palace who he has appointed ambassador to the sublime ambassador to the sublime port in constantinople exactly to the sultan peter the great says i would like a black child to be part of my cabinet of curastis procure me a black boy and um this guy he procures our friend the future ganabel who is only seven he basically by we don't know whether he buys him whether he does a deal with the sultan it's this is a mystery so much of, Tom, is a bit of a mystery. But he's brought back for the auspices of the Russian diplomatic service to St. Petersburg. Interestingly, one of the people whose path he crosses, who is sort of one of the orchestrators of this mission, is a man called Pyotr Andreevich Tolstoy, the great-grandfather of Tolstoy. So there's not just Pushkin, there is Tolstoy in this story.
他被任命为前往崇下门（Sublime Porte）即君士坦丁堡的大使，彼得大帝对他说：“我想要一个黑人小孩加入我的珍宝柜，给我弄一个黑人男孩来。”然后，这个人……他给我们物色了我们的朋友、未来的加尼巴尔，当时他只有七岁。他基本上是通过……我们不知道他是买下的，还是与苏丹达成了某种交易，这是一个谜。汤姆，很多事情都有点像个谜。但他被带回了圣彼得堡，交由俄罗斯外交部门照料。有趣的是，与他擦肩而过、作为这次任务的策划者之一的人，是一个名叫彼得·安德烈耶维奇·托尔斯泰（Pyotr Andreevich Tolstoy）的人，也就是托尔斯泰的曾祖父。所以这个故事里不仅有普希金，还有托尔斯泰。
Is there a Dostoevsky who pops up? There's no Dostoevsky. I'm sorry to disappoint you. So Gannibal, and we'll call him Gannibal, he arrives in St. Petersburg, and he's presented to Peter the Great as a gift. Peter the Great takes a great shine to him. A year later, he has him baptised in Vilnius, which is then part of the Russian Empire. And Peter the Great himself serves as the boy's
这里面会不会蹦出一个陀思妥耶夫斯基？没有陀思妥耶夫斯基。我很抱歉让你们失望了。于是加尼巴尔——我们就叫他加尼巴尔吧——他抵达了圣彼得堡，并作为礼物被献给彼得大帝。彼得大帝对他的喜爱溢于言表。一年后，他在维尔纽斯（Vilnius，当时属于俄罗斯帝国的一部分）让他受洗。有趣的是，彼得大帝本人亲自担任了男孩的教父。那么彼得大帝在这里究竟想做什么呢？嗯，我认为他试图做的是，他把自己看作一个伟大的收藏家，一个拥有各种奇珍异宝的人。加尼巴尔就是其中的一件珍宝，但他也想走得更远。汤姆，彼得大帝正如我们所知，是一位伟大的现代化推行者……是的，启蒙运动的人物。
godfather, interestingly. So what is Peter the Great up to here? Well, I think what he's trying to do is he sees himself as a great collector, as a man who has all sorts of curiosities. And Gannibal is one of the curiosities but he also wants to go further peter the great tom is a great modernizer as we know yes a figure of the enlightenment is a figure of the enlightenment and it's very important to him that he has what he sees as this sort of exotic strange non-christian boy and he is going to, in averted commas, civilize and modernize him. So he has Gannibal taught, little boy taught, mathematics and engineering. And the boy proves a whiz at it, an absolute whiz. He's got a real appetite for him. So he accompanies Peter the
他是一个启蒙运动的人物，对他来说最重要的是拥有他眼中这种异国情调的、奇特的、非基督教的男孩，他要……加上引号……教化和现代化这个男孩。因此，他让人教导加尼巴尔——这个小男孩——数学和工程学。而这个男孩在这方面表现得极有天赋，简直是个天才。他对此有着真正的热情。所以他随彼得大帝出行。彼得大帝是一个伟大的旅行家。他去过荷兰。他去过巴黎。他们在1717年去了巴黎。当时这个男孩，你知道，正处于十几岁的晚期，彼得大帝对他说：“听着，你在数学和工程学方面非常出色。为什么不留在这里的法国学习科学呢？”于是这个男孩留下了。他会说好几种语言。他学了几何。
Great when he travels. Peter the Great is a great traveler. He goes to the Netherlands. He goes to Paris. And they're in Paris in 1717. So when the boy is, you know, in his late teens, and Peter the Great says, listen, you're tremendously good at maths and engineering. Why don't you stay here in France and study science? So the boy does. He speaks several languages. He's learned geometry.
他学了所有这些东西。他加入了法国军队。并在1720年进入了法国炮兵学院。所以这里有点拿破仑的影子？是的，是的，而且他很幸运，因为如果他想经历战火的话，恰恰在这个时候爆发了一场名为“四国同盟战争”（War of the Quadruple Alliance）的战争，现在几乎快被遗忘了。交战双方一边是法国、英国、神圣罗马帝国和荷兰共和国，另一边是西班牙。于是他出发了，这个现在已经长大的年轻人……
He's learned all these things. He joins the French army. And in 1720, he enters the french artillery academy so a bit of a sort of hint of bonaparte here yes yeah and um he's lucky because if he wants to see action because at precisely this point a war breaks out called the war of the quadruple alliance almost completely forgotten now between um france brit, the Holy Roman Empire, and the Dutch Republic on one hand, and the Spanish on the other. And off he goes, this young man as he now is,
这个年轻的喀麦隆小伙子。他前往比利牛斯山脉，在那里指挥一个炮兵部队。他协助攻占了巴斯克地区的几个西班牙城镇。但他也是个伟大的发明家和爱搞发明创造的人。他发明了一门自己设计的加农炮，并试射了它。实际上，就像18世纪许多加农炮常有的情况一样，它发射了，但不幸的是，朝向了……
this young Cameroonian man. He goes off to the Pyrenees, where he commands an artillery unit. He helps to capture several Spanish towns in the Basque country. But he's a great inventor and a tinkerer. And he's invented a cannon of his own design, which he fires. And it actually, as often happens with a lot of 18th century cannons, it fires, but unfortunately, in the
错误的方向。它基本上差点把自己的头给炸飞，头部受了重伤，并被西班牙人俘虏了。因此他在西班牙的监狱里度过了两年。后来他被释放并回到了巴黎。在那里，他成为了一个巨大的名流。所以多米尼克，这是18世纪初。是的。而18世纪初正是大西洋世界的奴隶贸易真正蓬勃发展的时候。
wrong direction. And it basically almost blows his own head off and suffers a bad head injury and is captured by the Spanish. So he ends up in Spain for two years in a Spanish prison. Then he's released and he comes back to Paris. And there he's a tremendous celebrity. So Dominic, so this is early 18th century. Yes. And the early 18th century is where the slave trade is really kicking in, in the Atlantic world.
是的。人们常说欧洲是种族主义的温床，但这……他的职业生涯似乎表明并非如此。是的，好吧，大家都知道他是彼得大帝的好友，你看，彼得大帝非常喜欢他，他拥有沙皇的认可。但我也认为，公正地说，他是一个新奇事物，人们绝对没有敌对排挤他。所以当他回到巴黎时，巴黎人……他们就是叫他汉尼拔的人。因为他在西班牙的功绩。
Yeah. And it's often said that europe is a hotbed of racism but this would his career would seem to uh suggest otherwise yes well everyone knows that he's peter the great's pal you see and that peter the great is very fond of him and he has the sort of czar's uh approval but also i think it's fair to say he's a novelty but people certainly don't take against him. So when he goes back to Paris, the people in Paris, they are the people who call him Hannibal. Because of his exploits in Spain.
他在西班牙的功绩，以及整个迦太基与非洲的联系，他们管他叫汉尼拔。现在，俄罗斯人把这个词发音为“加尼巴尔”。因此，这就是为什么他被称为加尼巴尔。但他混迹于巴黎的启蒙运动圈子。据说伏尔泰曾称他为“俄罗斯启蒙运动的黑暗之星”。这可能有点虚构。几乎每一篇关于汉尼拔的故事都会重复这一点。但让我们假设伏尔泰真的这么说过。因为伏尔泰对非洲人其实相当种族主义。
His exploits in Spain and because of the whole Carthaginian-African link, they call him Hannibal. Now, the Russians pronounce that Hannibal. Hence, that's why he's called Gannibal, as it were. But he mixes in kind of enlightened circles in Paris. Voltaire is said to have called him the dark star of the Russian enlightenment. And this may be a bit apocryphal. It's repeated by almost every single story about Hannibal. But let's imagine that Voltaire really did say it. Because Voltaire was quite racist towards Africans.
所以很高兴看到他在那里没有表现出种族主义。他对汉尼拔挺好的。是的。1723年，他带着名人般的光环回到了俄罗斯。汤姆，我想我们应该在这里休息一下。休息过后，我们再来讲述这个喀麦隆男孩的不可思议的故事，并跟随他的轨迹，看看他是如何在俄罗斯帝国成为一名将军和贵族的。太棒了。等不及了。几分钟后见。
So good to see him not being racist there. It was nice about Hannibal. Yeah. And in 1723, he goes back to Russia as a bit of a celebrity. And Tom, I think we should take a break here. And then we should pick up this incredible story of this Cameroonian boy and follow his trajectory to a general and a nobleman in the Russian Empire after the break. Fantastic. Can't wait. See you back in a few minutes.
我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们共同主持《娱乐的余烬》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论以及少许的八卦爆料。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部，如果你想要无广告收听、加更节目以及现场门票的优先购买权，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。大家好，欢迎回到《历史的余烬》。在多米尼克的讲述下，我们正在进行这个非凡故事的中段。我觉得毫不夸张地说，这个人可能是18世纪喀麦隆出身的最著名的人物。如果有喀麦隆历史专家能纠正我们的说法，请让我们知道。但我猜他很可能……绝对是18世纪在俄罗斯成为将军的最著名的喀麦隆人。我认为这毫无疑问是真的。所以……所以他是一个……这个年轻的喀麦隆男孩，曾在君士坦丁堡做过奴隶，作为男童侍从被送给彼得大帝，他后来成为了一名炮兵专家，在巴黎学习过炮兵。他现在回到了俄罗斯，而你将接着讲述这个故事。他作为一颗巨星回到了俄罗斯。彼得大帝对他的印象非常深刻。你知道，他完全证明了彼得对他的信任等等。所以他回来了。他将成为一名军事工程师，彼得任命他为帝国近卫军的数学导师，这可以说是……是的……
I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our members club if you want ad-free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Hello welcome back to The Rest Is History and And courtesy of Dominic, we are midway through the remarkable story of the man I think it would be no exaggeration to say is probably the most famous person to have come from Cameroon in the 18th century. If there are specialists in Cameroonian history who could put us right on that, let us know. But I suspect he probably is certainly the most famous cameroonian to have become a general in russia in the 18th century i think that's unquestionably true so so so he's he's um he this young cameroonian boy who a slave in constantinople been given as a
但是对于加尼巴尔先生来说是个坏消息，因为在1725年，彼得大帝去世了，他的遗孀叶卡捷琳娜成为女皇叶卡捷琳娜一世。但真正的大权在握的强人是一个叫缅希科夫亲王（Prince Menshikov）的人。而缅希科夫亲王一点也不认可加尼巴尔。他认为他很粗俗，出身低微，是个前奴隶，还是个外国人，而且不管怎么看，他都不是什么好东西。汤姆，你看上去好像正准备说点什么，是吗？没有，没有。我只是在想，真是个混蛋。对，没错。嗯，他确实是个混蛋。
page boy to peter the great he's become an artillery expert, an artillery studied in Paris. He's now come back to Russia and you're going to take up the story. He's come back to Russia as a great star. Peter the Great is very impressed with him. You know, he's absolutely vindicated all Peter's sort of faith in him and whatnot. So he comes back. He's going to be a military engineer and Peter appoints him tutor of mathematics to the imperial guard which is you know yeah um yeah but bad news for uh for um mr cannibal because in 1725 peter the great dies and his widow catherine becomes czarina catherine the first but the big strong man is a guy called prince menschikov and prince menschikov it does not approve of Gannibal at all.
在这方面，缅希科夫绝对是个混蛋。是的。因此，在1727年，也就是掌权两年后……缅希科夫以强人的姿态入局，可怜的老阿夫拉姆·彼得罗维奇·加尼巴尔最终陷入了一种半流放状态，被贬到了西伯利亚的一个偏远职位。不仅是西伯利亚，还是一个名叫谢连金斯克（Selen ginsk）的地方，基本上就在中国边境旁边。这离喀麦隆可真够远的，不是吗？我的意思是，那离……不仅是西伯利亚，还是一个名叫谢连金斯克的地方，基本上就在中国边境旁边。这离喀麦隆可真够远的，不是吗？我的意思是，那离喀麦隆太远了，汤姆。这是无可否认的。
He thinks he's vulgar, he's from below, he's an ex-slave, and he's a foreigner, and he's just a bad sort, you know, all things considered. Tom, you look as though you're gearing up to say something, are you? No, no. I was just thinking, what a rotter. Yeah, good. Well, he is a rotter.
他是个见多识广的人，这么说吧。在那里，他们基本上让他指导修建一座大型要塞，以抵御来自中国人的任何潜在进攻。于是加尼巴尔在那里呆了两年。两年后，好消息来了，缅希科夫亲王死了。万岁。这对加尼巴尔来说是个好消息。
Menshikov's an absolute rotter in this regard. Yeah. So in 1727, so two years after taking menschkoff has sort of come in as the strongman poor old avram petrovich ganabel ends up in a sort of semi-exile kind of remote posting to siberia and not just siberia but a place called selen ginsk which is basically right next to the chinese border it's about a far away from cameroon isn't it i mean that's a hell of a way from and not just Siberia, but a place called Selenginsk, which is basically right next to the Chinese border. It's about a far away from Cameroon, isn't it? I mean, that's a hell of a way from Cameroon, Tom. There's no disguising it.
是的。因为女皇说：“你不再处于流放状态了。你可以在西伯利亚多呆一会儿。如果你能在西伯利亚多呆几年，做更多的建设工作，那就更好了，但我会授予你一个头衔。我们现在称你为主工程师。”于是他照做了。然后他回到了西方。现在，汉尼拔的生活可以说是起起落落，汤姆。1731年，他结婚了，他娶了一个名叫叶夫多基亚·迪奥皮（Yevdokia Diopi）的希腊女子。现在，这听起来……他结婚了这很好。
He's a well-traveled man, let's put it that way. And there they basically get him to direct the construction of a big fortress to fend off any possible attacks from the Chinese. So Gannibal is there for two years. And after two years, good news, Prince Menshikov dies. Hooray. That's great news for Gannibal.
这对他来说是件好事。但不幸的是，他的妻子极其厌恶他。那他们为什么要结婚呢？好吧，据说，这很难弄清真相。我的意思是，正如我在上半部分所说的那样，很多事情都非常神秘。很难弄清楚是宫廷命令他们结婚的，因为结婚很重要，还是他想结而她不想。而宫廷基本上支持了他，迫使她嫁给了他。基本上在很短的时间内，也就是几个月之内，加尼巴尔就认为这个希腊女人在背叛他。
Yeah. Because the Tsarina says, you're no longer kind of in exile. You can hang around in Siberia. It would be nice if you hung around in Siberia for a couple more years, do more building work, but I'll give you a title. We'll call you a master engineer now. So he does that. And then he comes back to the West. Now, it swings and roundabouts with Hannibal's life, really, Tom. In 1731, he marries, and he marries a Greek woman called Yevdokia Diopi. Now, that might sound, you know, it's great that he's got married.
而汤姆，当她生下一个完全是白人的孩子时，他的怀疑得到了证实。加尼巴尔认为，是的，这绝对不对劲。于是他下令逮捕了她，她因通奸罪被判入狱11年。嗯，严厉但务实。是的，是的，我想这是一个公正的判决。现在，与此同时，他遇到了另一个人。
It's nice for him. But unfortunately, his wife absolutely detests him. So why did they marry him? Well, supposedly, it's hard to find the truth of this. I mean, again, as I said in the first half, a lot of it is very mysterious. It's hard to work out whether they were ordered to by the court because it was important they get married or he wanted to, but she didn't. And the court kind of backed him and forced her to marry him. Basically, quite early on, within a matter of kind of months, Gannibal thinks that this Greek lady is betraying him.
他遇到了一位名叫克里斯蒂娜·雷吉娜·舍贝里（Christina Regina Sjöberg）的波罗的海女贵族，她有着斯堪的纳维亚背景，他彻底爱上了她。并在1736年娶了她。现在，这里有一个小……这是一种重婚关系。是的，这里有一个小缺点，那就是他还没有和身在监狱里的叶夫多基亚离婚。
And his suspicions are confirmed, Tom, when she has a child who turns out to be completely white, which Gannibal sees as, yes, this is not the thing at all. And he has her arrested, and she's sent to prison for 11 years for adultery. Well, harsh, but robust. Yes, yeah, I suppose that's a fair verdict. Now, in the meantime, he meets somebody else.
因此，当局作为惩罚，让他支付了巨额罚款。好吧，但他非常乐意支付这笔罚款，因为这是一桩美满的婚姻。他们育有十个孩子。哦。而当他的前妻被释放出狱时，她被迫进入了一座修女院。所以我想这给任何考虑对俄罗斯将军不忠的人上了一课。那么，在这十个孩子中，有两个值得一提。其中最大的一个叫伊凡（Ivan），他成为了一名海军军官。汤姆，你敢信吗，他在乌克兰南部的赫尔松（Kherson）建市过程中发挥了关键作用。
He meets a kind of Baltic noblewoman called Christina Regina Sjöberg, who's got a kind of Scandinavian background, and he falls completely in love with her. And he marries her in 1736. Now, there's a slight... There's a kind of bigamous relationship. Yes, there's a slight drawback here, which is that he's not divorced from Yevdokia, who's in prison.
目前非常受关注。是的。当下因为乌克兰和俄罗斯之间争夺赫尔松的战斗。而伊凡成为了一名总司令，就像他的父亲后来做的那样。另一个值得注意的孩子叫奥西普（Osip），他有一个女儿叫娜杰日达（Nadejda），而她就是普希金的母亲。所以这就是你和诗人亚历山大·普希金的联系。你知道……他还有哪些其他著名的后代吗？这就是你在播客开头警告过我的、你要抛出的那个冷门知识吗？你对此很得意吧？是的，汤姆，我等不及了，因为我不知道……我能说吗？好的，对。所以……这是另一档历史播客主持人的孩子们，他曾做过我们的节目嘉宾，一个绝妙的人。是丹·斯诺（Dan Snow）吗？对，对，你因为他的……那只是随口开玩笑的胡闹……不，所以丹的妻子埃德温娜（Edwina）……是的……是威斯敏斯特公爵的女儿，而公爵夫人则是加尼巴尔的后代。所以丹的孩子们是加尼巴尔的后代。
So the authorities make him pay a heavy fine as a punishment. Right. But he's perfectly happy to pay that because this is a splendid union. They have 10 children. Oh. And when his previous wife is released from prison prison she's forced into a nunnery so i think there's a moral there for anyone it's thinking of cheating on a russian general so so of these of these 10 children two of them are worth noting so one of them the oldest one is is called Ivan, and he becomes a naval officer. And would you believe, Tom, he is instrumental in founding the city of Kherson in southern Ukraine.
那么，为什么丹·斯诺没有做这个节目呢？我们抢在他前面了。嗯，也许他做过。但我昨天在谈论加尼巴尔时读到了这个。好吧，我只是想确认这不只是某种互联网上的……然后他说，不，他对此感到极其自豪。
Very much in the news. Yes. At the moment, because of the battle for Kherson between Ukraine and Russia. And he becomes a general-in-chief, Ivan, as his father goes on to do. And the other child worth noting is called osip and he has a daughter called nadeja and she is the mother of pushkin so there's your link to alexander pushkin the poet do you know um some other famous descendants that he had is this your fact that you warned me at the beginning of the podcast you're going to
理所当然。我的意思是，加尼巴尔，正如你绝对说过的，是喀麦隆人成为俄罗斯18世纪将军中最著名的一个。好吧，他是个非常有趣的人，不是吗？我希望丹不会介意我宣读他的私信。所以我问，埃德温娜真的是加尼巴尔的后代吗？他说绝对是的，这是非凡自豪感的来源。罗曼诺夫、普希金、非洲王子血统，大有来头。所以，是的，巨大的自豪感，汤姆。我甚至有点后悔选了这个话题了，多米尼克。胡说八道。无论如何，听着……所以加尼巴尔的麻烦都抛在脑后了。新女皇伊丽莎白一世——我们在英语世界里这样称呼她——她是一个狂热的法兰西迷，汤姆。
bring out and you're very pleased with yourself yes i can't wait for it tom because i don't know what can i tell it to okay yes so uh it's the children of um the uh the presenter of another history podcast who's been on our he's been a guest on our show wonderful man is it dan snow yeah yeah who you called deranged because of his uh that was just that was just bad knock about no so dan dan's uh wife edwina yeah is uh the daughter of the duke of westminster whose wife is descended from ganableibal. So Dan's children are descended from Gannibal.
而前任掌权者……则是德国迷。所以她是个狂热的法兰西迷，因此她对加尼巴尔印象极深，因为他在巴黎的种种经历以及他对法军的服务。于是他带着全部荣誉重返宫廷。他成为了一名将军。他被派往现称塔林（Tallinn，位于波罗的海沿岸）的里瓦尔市（Rival）担任总督。
So how is it that Dan Snow hasn't done it? We've beaten him to it. Well, maybe he has. But I read this yesterday when I was talking about Gannibal. Well, I just wanted to check that it wasn't a kind of internet, you know. And he said, no, he's terribly proud of it.
他是塔林的统治者。他担任塔林总督将近十年。正是在这个时候，即1742年，他给伊丽莎白写了一封信，基本上是请愿，请求加入贵族阶层并获得一个族徽。他设计了自己的盾徽。他想在盾徽上画一头大象，还有喀麦隆的……所以大象大概是对汉尼拔、非洲和汉尼拔的一种暗示？没错，没错。还有这个神秘的词。对，F-U-M-M-O。现在，关于这个词有两种可能的解释。其中一种是，正如我在前半部分所说的那样，它在喀麦隆的科托科语中确实是“故乡”的意思。另一种有点令人失望的解释是，它实际上代表了一个拉丁语短语：Fortuna vitam mea mutavit omnino。
Rightly so. I mean, Gannibal, as you absolutely said, by far the most famous Cameroonian to become a Russian 18th century general. Well, he's a very kind of interesting man, isn't he? And I hope Dan won't mind me reading his private message. So I asked, was it really true that Hedwina was descended from ganabel and he said absolutely and it's a source of extraordinary pride romanov pushkin african princely descent big time so yeah yeah huge cause of pride tom i actually wish i hadn't chosen it now dominic nonsense anyway listen um so things cannibal's troubles are behind him there's a new uh czarina elizabeth the first as we know her in in the english-speaking world um she is a great francophile
汤姆，这意味着“命运彻底改变了我的生活”，对于他来说，这将是一个很好的座右铭。那么对此有什么共识吗？没有人知道。没有人知道。没有人知道。但我们确实知道的是，伊丽莎白一世确实给了他一块位于俄罗斯西北部一个叫米科莱夫斯科耶（Mikolayovskoia）地方的庄园，以及数百名农奴。所以他现在是一个大权贵了。他是一个大人物。他在1756年被任命为整个俄罗斯军队的首席军事工程师。随后在1759年晋升为将军。他现在是一个上了年纪的人了。最终，在1762年，伊丽莎白去世了。你的一个老熟人，汤姆，叶卡捷琳娜大帝（Catherine the Great）作为女皇登基了。加尼巴尔现在知道自己已经过时了，他是旧政权的象征。
tom whereas the the previous incumbent um had been uh germanophiles so so she's a great francophile and therefore she's very impressed with Hannibal, with all his stuff in Paris and his service to the French army. So he now enters the court with full honours. He becomes a general. He is sent to the city of Rival, which we know now as Tallinn on the Baltic, as governor.
所以他做的最后一件事情是，作为工程师，他在圣彼得堡冬宫外为新女皇组织了一场盛大的烟花表演。然后他退休回到了他在米科莱夫斯科耶的庄园，并于1781年在那里的逝世，当时他大概85岁。他熬过了八位沙皇，真是个令人惊叹的故事。离喀麦隆非常遥远，但实际上故事并没有真正在那里结束，因为他的传奇显然代代相传。它在普希金身上延续，普希金对自己的这种理想化设想——他认为自己是某个阿比西尼亚王子的后代，因为这天生让他显得更具吸引力和诗意。
He's the governor of Tallinn. He's the governor of Tallinn for the best part of a decade and it's at this point that in 1742 he um sends elizabeth a letter basically petitioning can he join the nobility and have a coat of arms and he's designed his own crest he wants a crest with an elephant on it and with the cameroonian so the elephant presumably is an allusion to hannibal africa and hannibal exactly exactly and this mysterious word. Yeah. F-U-M-M-O. Now, there are two possible explanations for this word. So one of them is that it does mean, as I said in the first off, homeland in the Kotoko language from Cameroon. The other rather disappointingly is that it actually stands for a Latin expression, Fortuna vitam mea mutavit omnino,
当然，这让他显得更吸引人。而且事实上，随着19世纪的推移……你之前谈到了18世纪的种族主义，但随着19世纪的推移，我认为对于俄罗斯人来说，他不是一个黑人撒哈拉以南非洲人，而实际上是一个基督教的埃塞俄比亚人，这一点变得越来越重要。对。是的。例如，普希金的一位朋友在19世纪30年代谈到加尼巴尔时说：“他身上没有一点黑人的特征。他是阿比西尼亚人。他有着端正的五官，表情残酷但聪慧。”我的意思是，这完全是捏造的。他根本没有任何理由知道这一点。他们开始叫他“黑奴”（The Moor）。
which means, Tom, fortune has changed my life entirely, which would be a great motto for him. And so what's the consensus on that? No one knows. No one knows. No one knows. But what we do know is Elizabeth I, she does give him, she gives him an estate in a place called Mikolayovskoia
这是一种刻意的、莎士比亚式的基调。他有点像奥赛罗（Othello）。是的，绝对是的。带有刻意的莎士比亚式余音。普希金的公寓里有一幅肤色较暗的贵族肖像画，学者们曾认为，这一定就是加尼巴尔。事实上，英国作家休·巴恩斯追踪到了这幅肖像。它被藏在普希金博物馆里。
in northwestern Russia, and hundreds of serfs. So he's a big magnate now. He's a big man. He's made the chief military engineer of the entire Russian army in 1756. Then he's raised to the rank of general in 1759. And he's an aging man now. And eventually, 1762, Elizabeth dies. And a friend of yours, Tom, Catherine the Great, comes in as empress. And Hannibal knows now that he's kind of past it and he's a symbol of the old regime.
它被放在一个阁楼里。他要求他们把它清理干净。当他们清理干净后，结果发现这实际上是一个白人的肖像。所以它根本不是加尼巴尔。但在苏联时期，加尼巴尔甚至还扮演过一定的角色。所以苏联在冷战期间显然非常渴望把自己表现为反种族主义者，以此对比种族主义的美国人。
So the last thing he does is he organizes a massive, as the engineer, he organizes a massive fireworks display for the new Tsarina outside the Winter Palace in St. Petersburg. And then he retires to his estate in Mykolaivsk, where he dies in 1781 at the age, I think, probably of 85. And he has outlived eight Tsars and sorry astonishing story and he's an awfully long way from cameroon but actually the story doesn't really end there because his legacy obviously lives on it lives on in pushkin um and pushkin sort of pushkin's ideal that he has been descended from this sort of vision that he has that he's been descended by from an abyssinian prince because it inherently makes it more interesting and poetic of course
是的。作为其中的一部分，他们在1976年拍了一部名为《彼得大帝怎样娶了他的黑奴》（How Tsar Peter the Great Married Off His Moor）的电影。一个叫弗拉基米尔·维索茨基（Vladimir Vlisotsky）的人饰演了加尼巴尔，把他演成了一种……这是一部喜剧，但对于现代观众来说，稍微让它变得不好笑的地方在于，他完全把脸涂黑来扮演加尼巴尔，所以这很难看下去。你没看过《凯瑟琳大帝》（The Great）吧？就是那个我认为非常滑稽、黑暗、带点超现实色彩的关于叶卡捷琳娜如何成为女皇的剧集。我很惊讶加尼巴尔没有被写进去，因为他本来可以很出彩的。我不知道他们为什么没把他放进去。好吧，我告诉你，20世纪初的黑人美国作家会非常失望，因为这就是故事结束的地方。所以，你有了这个喀麦隆小伙子。我们实际上对他的了解少之又少。坦白说，我所概述的轮廓可能就是我们所知道的全部了。我们知道他是个奴隶。我们知道他来到了圣彼得堡。我们知道他有着辉煌的军事生涯，然后是一名工程师，等等等等。但除此之外的一切都有点像个谜。但在20世纪，他成为了一些非常具有20世纪色彩的……他变成了一个偶像。
it makes it more interesting yeah and actually as the as the 19th century goes on you were talking about racism in the 18th century but as the 19th century goes on i think it becomes more and more important to russians that he is not a sort of black sub-Saharan African, but in fact, a Christian Ethiopian. Right. Yeah. So for example, a friend of Pushkin's says in the 1830s about Gannibal, there was nothing of the Negro in him. He was Abyssinian. He had regular features, a cruel but intelligent expression. I mean, that's just completely made up. There's no reason for him to know that. They start to call him the Moor.
这确实让事情更有趣了。事实上，随着19世纪的推移——你刚才谈到了18世纪的种族主义——但随着19世纪的发展，我认为对俄罗斯人来说，他不是那种黑人撒哈拉以南非洲人，而实际上是一个基督教埃塞俄比亚人，这一点变得越来越重要。对的。是的。所以，例如，普希金的一位朋友在18世纪30年代谈到加尼巴尔时说，他身上没有一点黑人的特征。他是阿比西尼亚人。他五官端正，表情冷酷但聪明。我的意思是，这完全是凭空捏造的。他根本没有理由知道这一点。他们开始叫他摩尔人。
And it's sort of deliberate sort of Shakespearean. He's kind of a fellow. Yeah. Yeah, absolutely. Deliberate sort of Shakespearean overtones. And there's a portrait of a sort of nobleman with dark skin that Pushkin had in his apartment that scholars thought, well, this must be Gannibal. And actually, the British writer Hugh Barnes tracked this portrait down. It was hidden in the Pushkin Museum.
这有点像是刻意模仿莎士比亚式的风格。他有点像那种人。是的。是的，绝对是。带有故意的那种莎士比亚式的弦外之音。普希金的公寓里有一幅深色皮肤贵族的肖像，学者们曾认为，这一定就是加尼巴尔。事实上，英国作家休·巴恩斯追查到了这幅肖像。它被藏在普希金博物馆里。
It was in an attic. And he asked them to clean it. And when they cleaned it, it turned out that actually it was a portrait of a white man. So it wasn't Gannibal at all. But in the Soviet Union, Gannibal even played a part. So the Soviet Union, obviously in the Cold War, was very keen to present itself as anti-racist compared to the racist Americans.
它在阁楼里。他请他们清洗这幅画。清洗后，结果发现实际上这是一个白人的肖像。所以根本不是加尼巴尔。但在苏联时期，加尼巴尔甚至还扮演过某种角色。因此，苏联在冷战期间显然非常急于将自己塑造成一个反种族主义的国家，以此来对比种族主义的美国人。
Yeah. And as part of that, in 1976, they made a film called How Tsar Peter the Great Married Off His Moor. And a man called Vladimir Vlisotsky played cannibal and played him as a sort of it's a sort of it's a comedy um but what slightly makes it unfunny now i think for for modern viewers is that he's completely blacked up as cannibal so it's quite hard to watch you haven't watched the great have you which is the uh i think brilliant brilliantly funny dark kind of faintly
是的。作为其中的一部分，在1976年，他们拍了一部名为《彼得大帝怎样嫁掉他的摩尔人》的电影。一个叫弗拉基米尔·维索茨基的人饰演加尼巴尔，把他演成了一种——这其实是一部喜剧——但现在让现代观众觉得有点笑不出来的原因是，他为了演加尼巴尔把脸涂得全黑了，所以这片子现在看起来挺难接受的。你没看过《凯瑟琳大帝》吧？就是那个——我认为极其精彩、妙趣横生、带点黑暗风格且有些
surreal uh narrative of how catherine becomes sarina and i'm amazed that that ganabel wasn't included in that because he would have been brilliant i don't know why they didn't put him in well i'll tell you he'd be very disappointed black american writers of the early 20th century because this is the point where it's to end so you you've got this Cameroonian bloke. We actually know so little about him. The outline that I've given is probably as much as we know, to be honest. We know that he was a slave. We know that he came to St. Petersburg. We know he had this tremendous military career, and then an engineer, blah, blah, blah. But everything else is a bit of a mystery. But in the 20th century, he became an icon for some very 20th century he became an icon for
超现实的——关于凯瑟琳如何成为女沙皇的故事。我很惊讶加尼巴尔没有被写进那部剧里，因为他本可以非常出彩，我不知道他们为什么没把他放进去。好吧，我告诉你，20世纪初的黑人美国作家们会非常失望，因为这就是要收尾的地方。所以，你遇到了这个喀麦隆老兄。我们实际上对他的了解少之又少。老实说，我刚才给出的概况大概就是我们所知道的全部了。我们知道他曾是个奴隶。我们知道他来到了圣彼得堡。我们知道他有着辉煌的军旅生涯，后来成为一名工程师，等等等等。但其他一切都还是个谜。但在20世纪，他成为了某些极具20世纪特色的人的偶像，他成为了一个偶像
some very unlikely people he became an icon for the writers of the harlem renaissance in america so um was they did they know about him through pushkin or through pushkin you see they like they love the idea that pushkin the great russian writer was at heart an African. So Langston Hughes says of Pushkin in the 1920s, he was the first black writer to scale the mountain standing in the way of true Negro art in America. Paul Robeson talks a lot about Pushkin. And indeed, even today, there are critics who say that that book, The More of Peter the Great, Pushkin's book about his great grandfather is is, as one American critic puts it, the first work of fiction in modern times by a black writer with a black hero. The black writer, she thinks, is Pushkin, and the black hero is Avram Petrovich Gannibal, who, as you very rightly said, Tom, probably the most famous Cameroonian to have become a Russian general.
在一些不太可能的人当中，他成为了美国哈莱姆文艺复兴时期作家的偶像。所以，他们是通过普希金了解他的吗？你看，他们喜欢并且热爱这样一种观点：伟大的俄国作家普希金内心深处其实是一个非洲人。因此，兰斯顿·休斯在20世纪20年代谈到普希金时说，他是第一位登上阻碍美国真正的黑人艺术发展的山峰的黑人作家。保罗·罗伯逊也经常谈到普希金。事实上，甚至在今天，仍有评论家认为，那本《彼得大帝的黑奴》——普希金关于他曾祖父的书——正如一位美国评论家所说的那样，是近现代由黑人作家创作的、以黑人英雄为主角的第一部虚构文学作品。她认为，黑人作家是普希金，而黑人英雄则是阿夫拉姆·彼得罗维奇·加尼巴尔，正如你非常正确地指出的那样，汤姆，他可能是最著名的成为俄国将军的喀麦隆人。
Well, thank you very much, Dominic. That was absolutely wonderful. What an extraordinary story. And I have to say, I am loving doing these because, you know, we couldn't have done a whole episode on him, a kind of traditional episode, but just beautiful bite-sized subject. So thanks very much. Yeah, love that story. And we'll be back.
好的，非常感谢你，多米尼克。这真是太精彩了。多么传奇的故事啊。我必须说，我非常喜欢做这些节目，因为你知道，我们不可能为他单独做一个整集的传统节目，但这是一个精美的小菜。所以非常感谢。是的，我很喜欢这个故事。我们还会回来的。
We're back tomorrow with a couple more episodes. So see you then. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com.
我们明天会带着另外几期节目回归。到时候见。再见。再见。感谢收听《历史的余烬》。想要收听独家节目、提前获取内容、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请访问 restishistorypod.com。
That's restishistorypod.com. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. TheRestIsEntertainment.com There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
网址是 restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐的余烬》。TheRestIsEntertainment.com 本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。